[Music]
let's talk about bad moms very funny
idea why don't you set up the idea for
the films it's a really funny idea it's
it's it's a movie about six moms and
they're all kind of stereotypes of
different mothers that you may or may
not know and if you don't know them then
chances are you are one of them it's a
little bit about wish fulfillment but
mostly about overworked and
underappreciated women that kind of have
had enough and and just say I'm done and
they go upon this little journey to kind
of find themselves again as women and as
wives and his mother is in order to be
better parents for their kids and they
really cut loose there's a scene there's
a supermarket scene where the moms are
really just becoming completely
uninhibited and going for it yeah it's
written by the same guys are what the
hangover so when I tell you like keep in
mind funny things happen all the time
and there's you know fun cars and
sequences and everything's great and and
and just really over-the-top yeah yeah I
think we had a photograph from a scene
where literally you're just you guys are
going for it this is with fulfillment at
its - I don't know if you have this on
your bucket list but I did I've always
wanted to run through the grocery store
and just mayhem like just do whatever I
wanted to do like whip boxes open like
eat Doritos and do anything and note my
loan thanks you guys so it was just me
yeah and so we got to do it for 12 hours
is literally just run amok in a grocery
store and be completely debaucherous and
you just you were pouring like great
sugary cereals on each other and then
eating them off of each other's bodies
correct like some of it I may have a may
not have eaten some off of Katherine
hunts chest which is a wonderful chest
yeah yeah it's beautiful that is
combining so many of my adolescent
fantasies right now
Froot Loops on a boobie yeah that's
incredible
you